[Music]
[Applause]
Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one color
analyst and uh were you on the call for
anything this weekend
no actually I'll be on the call Saturday
for the Chiefs and the Raiders on that
Saturday double header but it was nice
actually Dan I was home on Christmas Eve
I was able to watch I'm sorry New Year's
Eve able to watch the college football
playoff game I think it was maybe my
second weekend since August 5th maybe
where I didn't have a game it was kind
of nice actually to just be a normal
human being on some level all right let
me ask you this question speaking of the
Raiders and the Chiefs that'll be on
Westwood one Saturday
if both were available
Derek Carr or Jimmy Garoppolo same price
who would you take moving forward
oh I would take Derek Carr yeah and
there are several reasons for that I
would say Dan the number one reason
though is just the injury history yeah
Derek Carr other than when he broke his
leg that one year when they went to the
playoffs he stayed very healthy and been
very durable Jimmy just has it and also
on some level Dan
feels like whoever else Kyle Shanahan
puts in an offense you watch him and
you're like this guy might be pretty
member CJ beathard Nick Mullins like all
these guys you're like you know what
this guy now is Brock Curry now Brock
Purdy's the guy that were like is he a
starter that's a great point it seems
like almost everyone that's in that
offense ends up playing pretty well I'll
take their car okay so what happened
with Derek Carr he was a healthy scratch
not gonna play against the Chiefs let
not scheduled to
why
Josh McDaniels and he were not a great
fit for some unknown reason you think
it's over you think it's over oh yeah
okay yeah I I think once you make this
move and you have them away from the
team like he wasn't even at the game
he's away from the team for these two
weeks it's tough to go back he's got
over 40 million dollars fully guaranteed
if he's on the roster by some date I
don't know if it's February 15th or
March 1st or whatever so I think they're
going to try to trade them I think to be
honest with you it's funny Dan because
it's a bad look
for Josh McDaniels because pretty much
across the board everybody was on the
same page Derek Carr was a top 12 maybe
top 10 quarterback last year after all
the Gruden stuff happened without
Devonte Adams he led them to the
playoffs heck they were inside the 20
against the Bengals in the Wild Card
round so Derek Carr was coming off a
really good year it's why Devonte Adams
wanted to go there it's why the Raiders
gave him a new contract and then this
year has just been bad really bad the
flip side of that though I guess is
Jared Stidham played so well yesterday
that that helps McDaniel's case a little
bit but I'm wondering about this in the
off season
the Tom Brady question will be out there
yeah because if you said to Tom Brady
who looked unbelievable yesterday
they're going to host the Cowboys
probably in the playoff game
and the off season coming up
could you see Tom Brady going to the
Raiders if let's say he plays one more
year more likely to go to the Raiders or
stay with Tampa Bay
Dan I'm going to take it a step further
I think Tom Brady will play next year
and I think Tom Brady will be a Raider
now there's a lot that has to happen
but I think it's more likely that he
plays than doesn't
he doesn't sound like a guy that wants
to retire
and I think it's more likely he goes to
the Raiders he's going to look at them
and see Josh McDaniels
they've got Chandler Jones and Max
Crosby off the edge Devonte Adams he
loves guys like Hunter Renfro we know
that Darren Waller at tight end you know
they tried to make this happen a couple
years ago evidently Dana White was
trying to broker the deal with Mark
Davis I don't know how that happened or
how that works but I just think Brady
would love to be in Vegas he'd love to
be with McDaniels I think Mark Davis
would love to have him I think McDaniels
would love to have him because then it's
year two McDaniels needs to win Brady
always wins I think there's a it's not a
hundred percent or even 75 but this is a
decent percentage chance that it happens
because you're looking at rating you say
all right you want to play you want to
play for a championship again what place
that's going to be open gives you the
best chance to win a championship I got
Josh Jacobs who is unbelievable this
year I got you know Adams I got you know
as you mentioned Crosby Chandler Jones
like I the one thing that appears to be
missing is you know consistent play at
the quarterbacking position not that I
know that Tom can but you know he's
single put him in Vegas
it's go time
honestly I I would not be surprised at
all I think there's a decent chance it
happens and the way Brady played
yesterday I hope he keeps playing a
couple more years if he can keep playing
like that unfortunately he hasn't played
like that very much this year Well it
helps that uh Mike Evans it felt like
was open every single time that Tom
threw the ball what was that don't know
what was that I mean we've been talking
for weeks about how Steve Wilkes has
done such a great job as the Panthers
interim coach and he might get the head
job
how you let Mike Evans get behind the
entire defense not once not twice but
three times they were up 14 nothing they
were up 21-10 in the fourth quarter and
they let it happen two more times oh
there's Mike Evans down the right
sideline oh wait there's Mike Evans now
that that was bizarre to me and probably
allowed David Tepper that owner for the
Panthers to dodge a bullet I'm not sure
Dan he really wanted to hire Steve
Wilkes but if you win the division you
have a home playoff game you probably
kind of have to so maybe that allows
Tepper now to hire the guy he really
wants to whoever that ends up being he's
Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one color
analyst he'll be on the call Westwood
One radio Saturday 4 30 Eastern Raiders
and the Chiefs all right if you ran the
Giants what do you do with Daniel Jones
what do you do with saquon Barkley
Daniel Jones at worst I franchise tag
him and I had a guy come on my podcast
that's this past week Dan uh Michael
janetti from Spa track
he thinks Daniel Jones going to get
offered a lot of money if he hits the
market I agree wait wait wait what's a
lot of money for Daniel Jones is he a 40
million dollar a year guy
so it's interesting because there really
isn't any Middle Ground between like the
high-end backups at 8 million and the
guy's making over 40 million there's
this huge wide Chasm I think Tannehill
yeah might be the only guy in between
and then guys like Geno Smith and Daniel
Jones probably should be in that really
they should be like 25 million a year
right that's what they should get this
off season yeah but it only takes one
team and Daniel Jones is Young
he runs very well and someone's going to
look at that and say you know what he's
never had a good old line he's never had
good receivers and he led this team to
the playoffs he's done a really nice job
guys like Daniel Jones 26 coming off a
season which they lead their team to the
playoffs they're healthy starting
quarterback they don't become available
how much would a team like the
commanders pay Daniel Jones to not only
get him as their quarterback but then
you leave the Giants with nobody feels
to me like if the Giants can't get a
deal done they're going to have to
franchise and they can't let them go to
free agency and what about saquon
Barkley
that's interesting right because they
can't franchise both of them my guess is
they'll be able to get a deal done with
one of them and franchise the other I
think they'll be able to get deal done
with Sequon because I don't think
there's as much of a market for saquon
as people might think the injury history
the position and there's a lot of
running backs they're going to be free
agents I mean you mentioned Josh Jacobs
with the Raiders he's a free agent too
so there's a lot of guys that are going
to be available at that position I think
the Giants probably get a deal done with
saquon who realizes I mean he's from
like an hour and a half from New York
you know in northeast Pennsylvania he
likes it there I think he understands
the value of the marketing there in New
York they're now making the playoffs I
think if they give him a pretty good
running back deal I think he takes it
and stays there
help me understand the Jim Harbaugh
situation where you've gone to the final
four back-to-back years
haven't played for a national
championship and the rumors with the NFL
here they come again that Denver
reportedly is interested in talking to
Jim Harbaugh last year it was the
Vikings what's going on with Jim
Harbaugh
you know last year
after the Vikings more or less turned
them down they decided they wanted to go
in a different direction with Kevin
O'Connell which by the way has been a
terrific hire Harbaugh said
I'm done with the NFL I want to be at
Michigan for as long as they'll have me
blah blah blah you know the interesting
thing is nobody really believes that
because most guys don't like the
recruiting part of it and you know that
Dan and now it's not just the recruiting
party now the transfer portal is
ever present I mean they've already lost
a couple kids to Iowa you know that
weren't playing quite as much as they
wanted at Michigan you got the nil stuff
I just think most coaches with what's
going on at the college level are going
to be very intrigued by the NFL where at
least there's a set standard of rules
and everybody knows what the playing
field is I would not be surprised if he
takes a head coaching job in the NFL I
think he'll probably get offered one
good to talk to you Happy New Year to
you thanks for joining us always
likewise happy New Year to you guys
that's Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one
color analyst will take break your phone
calls coming up next